it is possible that we have a bear out  here about a mile and a half and the way  the wind is blowing  whatever theoretically that can't smell  anything in camp right now the smell  would be going this way so that is a  bonus I need to get the generator on for  power if I get attacked if I get hurt I  need to make sure I have communications  electricity air-to-ground it's gonna  save my bacon when I need help  can't even begin to fathom getting hurt  again I need to get my generator running  this is my little Jen this right here is  gonna give me the power in camp to get  stuff done it hasn't run in four months  it may not want to get this in the  neutral position  that's tight that's tight all righty  little baby didn't want to keep brown a  minute  now I've got to go check camp make sure  that you know things are running  I have a huge cleanup job to do I don't  know exactly how I'm gonna get that done  go me get my ass to work